hello everyone I was watching the live
coverage from round 3 of the London
chest classic and I really thought all
the games would end in a draw I
personally don't mind the draws but you
know people do one do want to see what
people are like that and I was already
given up on the idea of showing you a
game from round 4
but then out of nowhere Fabiano Khurana
and Sergey Cara can come to the rescue
I'll let you see all the other games for
ourselves I decided to show this one
because this is the first game in 20
games that didn't end in a draw so
without further ado let's always get to
this game Fabiano has the white pieces
and he plays efore we have c5 the
Sicilian defense by Kerrigan Knight to
f3 d6 d4 see counters on d4 Knight
captures on d4 and Knight to c6 the
tamaño variation Knight to c3 and Queen
to c7 the Basra Cove Bishop to e3 e6
Queen to f3 and Knight to e5 Queen to g3
now pinning the knight b5 kurakin
castles Queen side and the knight to f6
we had f4 now of course nice - g4 is
played and what do you play here as
white bishop the g1 was played of course
you don't want to allow your dark
squared bishop to be captured so Bishop
to g1 creating this Knight opposition
towards the night and g4 h5 now adding
protection to the knight and also making
room for him to jump back to h6 if
needed and this is the moment as I watch
the live coverage Christian said that
this is actually where Kerrigan went
wrong in this position Cara can play d5
and it seems like you know it seems like
maybe it's a right call but it's
probably just too soon
better than you know committing
committing your pawn to e5 it says I
think Phil is or once said once you push
the pawn forward it can never go
backwards so better than this
was something like Bishop to d3 first
developing the bishop and now you're
giving black the option of making a move
and after something like Bishop to b7
now you're play h3 and after the knight
jumps to h5 now your pawn is still on e4
it's not only 5 and you're controlling
the f5 squares so this night on h6
doesn't really doesn't really have a
plan well at least for now what this
would this would have been good for for
karaoke but after h5 he played D 5 and
here he allowed b4 Knight to a4 was
played if you play each captures on f6
after B captures in C 3 and F captures
and g7 Bishop captures on g7 the Bishop
to Queen and bone are a bit too strong
you know it's a beautiful diagonal here
for this Bishop and the rook is ready to
jump to b8 this this King is gonna get
attacked
so after b4 Knight to a4 we have Knight
to d5 now Knight to b3 Bishop to b7 and
night 8 to c5 attacking the light square
bishop and this would be this would be
great if carotene capturing but to
Bishop to c6 of course not allowing it
and all the way to this move
this is move 15 karana played Bishop to
c6 and corona said in an interview with
Maurice after the game that this was
still his preparation so he didn't
remember what happens after Bishop to c6
he just says that you know the computer
may be slightly favored black where it
was in it was an equal position but he
knew that he was ok here so this is this
is how far they analyzed you know
variations and and prepare the games
Knight to e4 and here karana said that
from this move car can play Knight to e4
that now he's on his own
f5 and after this F I move Carrick and
said in an interview after game that he
was really baffled here he really had no
idea what to do here he considered the
he captures on f6 but then G captures on
f6 and you didn't really hurt black here
black has a beautiful bond chain in the
center and it's it's and it's not easy
your f4 pony's attacked with the knight
and the Queen so it's it's very hard to
find a plan for white here
so after f5 correct and decided to go
for h3 as the f1 is attacking this
Knight now the H bone is attacking the
g4 Knight h4 first giving the Queen back
and here Kerrigan says that he
definitely knew he was worse Queen to e1
now F captures on e4 h captures on e4
and Knight captures on f4 so we have
rook afters on h4 rook captures on h4
Queen captures on h4 and Queen captures
on e5 and here
Fabiano is up upon now he grabs that 'if
I've gone and he had the he really had
to check a couple of moves back like
maybe five moves before this position
that he will be able to capture this a
five pawn the move he needed to find was
Bishop to b4 of course this is expected
of Kerrigan and now any move but the one
Fabiano played and Fabiano plays it
instantly so you can be sure that
Fabiano saw this move way before this
position arose he plays Knight to g6 now
attacking whites Queen and if you play
Bishop captures then Knight captures on
h4 the knight is pressuring the g2 pawn
you can't develop your LightSquared
Bishop if you push something like g3 to
get rid of it then Knight comes to f3
this is this is an amazing position for
black and yet like is up a pawn so
probably probably a winning position me
I don't know if he would win this
position but it's a much much pleasant
to play this for black so after nine g6
Queen to h3 Cara King doesn't want to
exchange Queens and now comes Queen to
g5 also a very important moment in the
position as if you play the you know the
standard idea which is Bishop to e3
to get rid of the Queen then Queen to h4
forces a trade of Queens and again there
will be a favorable and game for black
so after this Queen to g5 check
King to be one was played and now Bishop
to d5 Bishop back to G 1 and we have
Bishop to e7 g3 now Knight to e5
we have Bishop to e2 Kerrigan has to
protect the g4 pawn Knight to f3 and now
this Knight is it is on this f3 square
and this is incredibly unpleasant for
white this the options of the this
Knight are amazing
so Kerrigan decides to get rid of it
Bishop captures an f3 he captures on f3
and now
Fabiano has unveiled his pawns and now
this pawn is ready to march forward
Bishop to d4 King to f6 adding more
protection to the the g7 pawn and now
the rook is free to roam wherever he
wants to go at night to c1 preparing it
to remain over tonight into the game
we have d6 933 and now e5 now the pawns
are ready to be pushed bishop to f2 now
Bishop to e6 again attacking the g4 pawn
and Knight captures on b4
so Sergei saw an opening to grab a pawn
he decided to equalize material but this
allows this allows Fabiano to pusher
even further he plays efore and well of
course the idea is now III if he manages
to push III this is this is game over
so first American plays Queen to H 1
this is stopping III would I order a
pretty simple tactic if III then Queen
captures on f3 this comes with check
then he picks up the pawn and now white
is completely winning this game so after
Queen to h1 rook the c8 was played and
we have Knight captures on a6 and this
was a I move like I mean there isn't a
good move for white here move like c3
would definitely have been better it
would you know add add protection from
the c8 rook and you know it would maybe
keep white in the game he could maybe
set up a bouquet
with the Queen Bishop and rook to stop
these pawns but it's hard to say
so after up to c8 Curtin decided to grab
the pawn Knight captures on a6 but now
this allows the Queen to a5 and now the
night is trapped sergey of course
counted on this there is no way to
protect the night so Queen to h5 with
check and now Sergey must force a trade
of Queens
Queen captures G captures on h5 and here
comes Bishop to g5 this Knight kurakin
has an a6 is pretty stranded there it's
very unlikely that he will get back into
the game and Fabiano is ready to push
III we have rook to e2 and then now
Bishop to c4 by Caruana would attempt on
the night on a6 there was an even
quicker winter disposition Bishop d2 now
attacking the rook rook has to move you
push you push III and if you capture
then Bishop to a5
White is lost here threatening the rook
if the rook moves you grab the seat upon
which is attacked by the rook and the
bishop the White has no defense against
all the threats so after work 3:1
Fabiana didn't go for the fastest when
he played Bishop to c4
this comes with a temple on the knight
Knight the b4 and now rook to e8 simply
preparing to push the pawn to e3 there
is there is no stopping this if you try
something like Bishop to e3 then simply
Bishop captures rook captures and f2 you
can't stop the DF bone from queening the
bishop is also guarding f1 and after
rook to e8 Carrick and played rook to e3
and as Yaser said in this position it is
a moment of desperation for kareoke
Bishop captures on e3 Bishop captures on
e3 and now Fabiano plays rook to e5 he
immediately sees the winning idea
attacking the h5 pawn there's only one
move the defense at g4 and now Caruana
plays but rock to g5 and of course it
seems like he's allowing Kerrigan to
capture it if he doesn't capture it he's
gonna grab the g4 pawn
if you capture of course f2 is coming
you can't stop promotion you have a dark
square Bishop and the night is too far
away
so after this beautiful rook to g5 move
a surveyor can resign the game or in
this position Sergei car can resign the
game and it's a it's a it's a wonderful
move after after 20 games played this
was the last game that was still being
played in round 4 and you know everybody
everybody wanted to have a winner you
know to break this this bad case of
onigiri and you know a winter was so now
hurricane is in first place no hurricane
is in last place and Fabiano Quran is in
first place and it's wonderful what
Yaser said it's like a crime and
punishment
you know yesterday hurricane committed a
crime when he accepted a draw in a
winning position so today he must be
punished and this is his punishment so
instead of grabbing 1st place yesterday
and now he gets last place today so yeah
that's the game Caruana
versus Kerrigan from round 4 of the
London chest classic I do hope you
enjoyed it as usual you can check two of
my previous videos here I would like to
thank Scott Baker for a contribution to
my channel I think a lot I really
appreciate it thank you all for watching
and I will see you soon